well I think that both are very
worthwhile goals so it has been amazing
what's been done for cancer treatment
over the last 20 years truly amazing and
not just for breast cancer all cancers
uh dr. Dennis Slamon the head of
oncology at UCLA Medical Center made
truly one of the biggest discoveries in
the history of cancer research when he
developed the hair to new and protein
and subsequently developed a therapy
based upon treatment directed against
her tuna called Herceptin it's
revolutionized breast cancer treatment
there are a lot of women even in my own
practice who had been getting Herceptin
with stage four disease for a number of
years and doing quite well it is
increased in newly diagnosed patients
who are here to positive markedly
increased their disease free survival so
you know and that's not chemotherapy so
that's what is more in the targeted
therapy room there are a number of other
targeted therapies on the horizon so new
drug research vaccine research really
looking at the human genome looking at
what we call single nucleotide
polymorphisms or SNP's you know just
little tiny nucleotide change and one
gene can inactivate the gene so brca1
and 2 those are tumor suppressor genes
one little abnormality in those then it
work so much and so you increase the
risk of breast cancer and we're looking
at a lot of these now so we know people
with lower levels of detoxifying enzymes
don't detoxify a lot of these
carcinogens as well and looking at
insulin-like growth factor there are a
lot of therapies that are being looked
at in relation to insulin like
growth factor vascular endothelial
growth factor of Aston has been used
that targets angiogenesis again a
targeted therapy that's not chemotherapy
and there are a number of combinations
of these type of compounds that are
being used for a variety of different
cancers in a variety of different stages
so clearly research money needs to put
in be put into this because we're living
in a country that were one in three
people developed cancer we need better
treatments and we need been to continue
to evolve on the other hand we also need
to focus on something different than
just the war on cancer the war on cancer
was first coined by President Nixon in
the 1970s said we need a major push to
find a cure for cancer and since then a
lot of great therapies that I've just
mentioned and many more have come out of
that war on cancer so that's important
but we also need a war on carcinogenesis
carcinogenesis refers to the causes of
cancer all the environmental toxins that
are out there that are not just out
there they're in our bodies okay so we
have polluted a lot of the planet and we
polluted our bodies and clearly i think
that the fact that childhood brain
tumors have increased dramatically since
1970 you know some cancer incidence has
actually gone down but many have gone up
and childhood leukemia has gone up and I
do believe that it's really no
coincidence that we're seeing you know
an epidemic of learning disabilities an
epidemic of you know developmental
disabilities we're seeing the incidence
of autism increased dramatically over
the last 30 years and I don't believe
that any of these are occurring in a
vacuum so I believe there's a link
between a lot of the illnesses that
we're seeing and the environmental
toxins that are ending up in our body
not just out in the environment so
there's no difference between the
external environment and our internal
environment so we need a war on
carcinogenesis as well as a war on
cancer a war on the causes of cancer as
well as treating at once it's already
occurred and I believe that's a war that
really can help prevent cancer I believe
that by minimizing people's exposures to
a lot of carcinogens we can affect
cancer incidence and I believe that
through a lot of the nutritional
modalities that I've just discussed we
can also improve not only cancer
survival below ribs well I think they're
all talking about it so you know I've
heard speeches were there all more
cognizant of the environment and I am
encouraged because that was not
something prior to this presidential
campaign you really heard people talking
about with any regularity and you know
was about a year ago that there was an
article in the front page of the New
York Times and the article was titled
the death of environmentalism and they
interviewed two researchers who
contended that the reason people didn't
care about the environment so much or
you know started to yawn or change the
channel when somebody was talking about
the environment is because they just
felt it was too big a problem you know
and there wasn't anything that they
could do about it but nothing could be
further from the truth because if people
can understand that the environment out
there is ending up inside you it's
affecting your health it's affecting
your children's health and you know
having been through breast cancer with
my own mother I know what a toll it
takes on families and you know from
taking care of patients every day with a
variety of different cancer I know the
toll the cancer can take and clearly we
know the incidence you know cancer
Americans under the age of 85 it's
become the leading killer it over to
heart disease so this is a big problem
and it's not a problem that just because
it's big should seem overwhelming it's a
problem you know we're very industrious
people we're a very industrious nation
we've had bigger problems and we've
solved them and this is about each
individual getting this kind of
knowledge understanding about what it is
they're putting into their bodies you
know how they can make their immune
system strong how they can make their
detoxification system strong this is
about educating each person and I think
it's you know a great question that you
asked earlier what about people that
don't have a lot of money well maybe
they won't be able to go out and buy
organic milk that they can do things
like you know drink green tea and
sensible things exercise more there was
a study in the New England Journal of
Medicine suggesting that up to twenty
percent of women's cancers were related
to just obesity there's an epidemic of
obesity in this country and you know the
reasons for that or not enough exercise
and too much intake and you know I think
there are other factors that caused that
as well there are a number of chemicals
for instance that we're exposed to that
in animal studies have shown they make
the animals eat more even when you cut
the animals caloric restriction and
they're given a lot of certain
pesticides and herbicide residues they
still don't lose weight and so you know
there are a number of things people can
do just by getting within their ideal
body weight we know that up to
twenty-five percent of all cancers are
related to diet and we know you know
about the connection with sugar with
high insulin levels with high insulin
growth factor levels so there are a
number of things people can do